we understand you've donated now to what
195 or so crowdfunding campaigns yeah on
Kickstarter I i just donated 190 fifth
project on IndieGoGo there's like
another 50 and seed in sprite there's a
few so what is it that motivates you to
put in money for those campaigns I think
it's a mixture i think it's the
fascination of like well if i can be one
of a thousand to put in a dollar and we
all put in a dollar then this person has
what they want so it's sort of like oh I
can be that 1000 or if I put in ten
dollars I can be that 100 or whatever it
is and you know it's just sort of like
crowdfunding is interesting because
sometimes you'll get hundreds and
hundreds of people that you don't know
that are all just chipping in there two
dollars or five dollars or ten dollars
and it's it's not much of a contribution
but it adds up if you multiply it and so
I kind of feel like I'm not I'm not
hundred there on that thousandth that
will make this person's day you know oh
also it's sort of like oh man my friends
making a project you know you pitch in a
chunk of money cuz you know they're
making their thing they're making their
dream happen like it's sort of now that
I've been through it like I did a full
crowdfunding Kickstarter video we're
making a short film we're trying to
raise the funds for the be effects this
was a short film called similar and you
know we got a lot of people to
contribute to it but it is a race you
know your crowdfunding is like a real
amazing time where it's just like
there's you can't think about anything
other than getting the word out and like
you know making an update video and up
posting you know new things and getting
people interested in like trying to get
film blogs to talk about it and so part
of its my admiration for other people
that are you know starting their
crowdfunding campaigns I just know I
just know what it's like I have been
there and it's just like wow you know
you know I've been through it and so hey
I know what you're going through I'll
help you out so so it sounds like it's
more than just the delivery of a t-shirt
or some
like that it's really being part of this
process and and being in sort of the
discovery of it and and yeah in the
trenches a little bit in terms of like
oh yeah they got this far yeah i think
you know if it was buying a shirt i
could buy a shirt anywhere I think it's
more like a belief in their project or
something about it that's inspiring to
me or something that's like really
interesting or profound or you know a
sci-fi project that's talking about a
topic that's like really fascinating or
you know a friends project it's like wow
like I totally want to see this happen
so so of those two hundred-plus for more
that you've donated to collectively with
Kickstarter IndieGoGo season spark how
many of those people have actually
finished their projects from your
knowledge it's fascinating it's an
amazing to walk because Kickstarter has
these like graphs and you can kind of
pull down like what you've donated to
and the types and how many and you can
like sort through like what's successful
and what's unsuccessful and stuff and I
feel it's like sixty to eighty percent
of the ones that I've contributed to
have gone successful and like I've been
a part of a few that just didn't make it
and you and you think to yourself you
think well man what you know what could
you have done different that would have
made it like successful it's just it's
it's it's tough you know when your
crowdfunding to have an unsuccessful
project and I definitely know people and
been you know part of different projects
so let's suppose they did reach their
goal but of those 200 some how many do
you know that have met their goals but
haven't finished the project oh okay
because they got in over their head
right or whatever so you have fun you
raise your money or whatever and then
you end up don't completing your film or
your project or whatever I mean some of
them are photo books I've been involved
with or other other art projects and I
think it you know I know for me for our
similar project we did in 2010 ok here
it is 2014
our films finally finished but you know
it's like you know you're on the hook
you're on the hook for those obligations
for the things that you're promising
people so we promised people t-shirts so
we got to make the t-shirts we promised
people to film so we got to finish the
film I think it comes down to like the
honesty of the whole idea the the idea
is that hey if you give me this i'm
going to give you that or hey there's
this thing that we want to do and if you
champion the idea and have enough people
do then we possibly could do it and some
crowdfunding campaigns make it totally
apparent that's like this might not
happen I don't be let down if we end up
like not having this but this is what we
want to do I think it's the way you
pitch it if you tell people like maybe
it's not going to work out then you
don't feel so bad when it doesn't but if
you're like this is going to happen then
you kind of gotta follow through I had
have you seen people not follow through
uh well I mean I'm I'm trying to follow
through on the one i did and i'm still
not finished i'm still on the hook for
different different things that we self
to finish we're making a photo book of
our project putting together
behind-the-scenes photos and stuff like
that and i still haven't made the book
it's something i'm in the process of you
know so yeah I think you know I've seen
people get frustrated at different
projects that didn't deliver what they
promised and if you don't need ten
dollars and they don't do what they
promised it's another thing but if you
donate you know a thousand remote you
know you want them to deliver the
promise and that's part of the ethos of
the whole crowd funding thing is if
enough people are keeping their word
then it's like a you know a viable
system for for raising funds for for our
projects so how has donating to all
these campaigns and following those
filmmakers journeys whether if it's just
receiving updates every once in a while
yeah how has that impacted you have you
seen what worked for you have you felt
inspired by have you felt put off by it
sometimes because you feel like it's too
hard you see somebody with a great
campaign they don't make it and you say
wow how is that possible
yeah I think well it's just inspiring
you see crowdfunding campaigns and
people make in seeing the updates i
really like the updates where it's like
you know here's an update an update sort
of like a blog post right if you're
interested in the project and you're
kind of following along it's sort of
like here's the newest news here's the
info doing updates is pretty important
because what it does is it like makes
the people that did contribute feel good
about their contribution and then it's
sort of like oh yeah it's a reminder and
if you're still in the process of
raising funds it's like a reminder so
that they those people can share with
their friends so it's sort of like you
you want to be active with it and I
remember what was similar we had dozens
and dozens and dozens of updates here's
the newest news hey we were on this blog
hey we have an update hey you know we're
in Spain we're doing this thing here's
another behind-the-scenes photo you know
you're kind of adding to the story where
it's not just your pitch video right so
so have you seen things that you knew
that's exactly how you wanted to
approach it whether it was people
letting their funders know with humor
that you know what this didn't work out
or what you know with were there certain
takeaways can you give me a story of
somebody's campaign that you saw that
you said I want to be just like that I
want to do it in that style I want to
deliver my message it you know it's a
full range I i think there's projects
that i thought were going to get funded
because they're so inspiring and they're
so magical and you know this
photographer person wanted to put
together this amazing travel blog about
different photography things and it was
just like really interesting to me i put
in my ten dollars but you know she
needed like 200 people to do that and it
didn't quite catch on fire and you
wonder like well how do these out of
these catch on fire what is what leads
something to be okay we made a hundred
percent of our of our goal sometimes
you're just shocked and you're like what
happened other projects my friend leah
is doing this unicorns movie right now
she's come on come on you know it's
the final day of the crowdfunding it
looks like she's going to finally make
it but man 72 hours ago it didn't look
like it so people will come together at
the end
I found that where it's like at the end
everyone knows you only have two days
left and you only need a few thousand
dollars more and so they'll help at the
end but it's really it's nerve-racking
to watch a project very end and any
advice for someone who's crowdfunding
has failed like maybe they sour toward
filmmaking or they sour toward their own
creativity yeah watched a couple of
failed projects you know my advice is do
it again man I mean that's that's the
joy that's it's not a one-time thing you
tried but do another do another version
like relationships yeah yeah what's
interesting is you already have the
people that donate to the first one that
will be willing to contribute your next
one so try it again you know maybe lower
your expectations a little bit and try
it again and and I've seen those I've
seen knows be successful
you